ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY. THIS IS OUR
FIRST HEARING OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND IT IS TO LOOK AT BILLS
THAT ARE STILL ON THE FILE FROM
LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE A FEW
AHEAD OF US. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
MENTION OR WELCOME SOME MEMBERS
WITH US TODAY WHO ARE
TEMPORARILY SERVING MISTER
BENNETT. IS BONTA AND THIS WEEK
SO WILL BE JOINING US TODAY
SINCE OUR COMMITTEE HAS LOST
THREE INDIVIDUALS. OVER THE LAST
SIX MONTHS AND THEN MR HOLDEN IS
NOT GOING TO BE WITH US TODAY
MISTER BENNETTI BELIEVE IS
SUBSTITUTING. FOR HIM. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT IT IS
WITH SOME GREAT SADNESS. THAT WE
ARE NO LONGER GOING TO BE HAVING
MISTER TOM CLARK. UNDER
COMMITTEE HE IS RETIRING SO THIS
WILL BE I THINK OUR LAST
HEARING. WITH THE BENEFIT OF HIS
GREAT WISDOM EXPERIENCE. AND
KNOWLEDGE AND THAT WILL BE A
MAJOR MAJOR HOLE AND OUR
ABILITY. TO ANALYZE ME WE WILL
CARRY ON BUT TOM'S WISDOM
PROFESSORIAL. BOTH KNOWLEDGE AND
DEMEANOR HAS BEEN AND THEN
MAZING ASSET. TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. SO SOME
PRACTICAL THINGS WE ARE STILL IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC SO WE
ARE ASKING EVERYONE TO WEAR FACE
MASKS AND SOCIALLY DISTANCE AS
IT DOES APPROPRIATE TO THAT WE
CAN GET THIS. SURGE BACK UNDER
CONTROL. THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE
TAKING TESTIMONY TELEPHONICALLY
AS WELL AS HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SO WE WILL BE TRYING TO
MANAGE THAT AS AS BEST WE- CAN
TODAY WE ASK THAT WITNESSES USE
THE MAIN MIKE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ROOM PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
PEOPLE THROUGH. AS READILY AS
POSSIBLE. THE KILEY NUMBERS WE
HAVE A TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
THOSE WHO WILL BE DIALING IN. IT
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
AGAIN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN AND THAT INFORMATION
WILL BE ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND SHOULD BE FOR THOSE WATCHING
. REMOTELY SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN AT THIS POINT. RIGHT WE
DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM OUR
QUORUM WILL BE SIX BECAUSE WE
ARE STILL OFFICIALLY HAVE ELEVEN
MEMBERS EVEN THOUGH WE'RE DOWN
QUITE A FEW WE WILL MANAGE THAT
TODAY BUT WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE WILL START
WITH I'VE NEVER TO HONOR AGENDA
MR JONES SAWYER AB. TEN NINETY
THREE. ONE IT IS GOOD TO BE ON
TIME. WELCOME GOOD MORNING- THIS
IS ALL. I HAVE I BELIEVE SO.
THAT'S THE ONE TWO THREE IS
THAT- THAT'S WITH THE OFF OKAY
TESTING WENT- MY GIRLS NOT SHOW
GO AHEAD OKAY GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- AB TEN
NINETY THREE- THIS BILL EXPANDS
ACCESS TO NOT MATERIAL SERVICES
FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BY
AUTHORIZING REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION ALSO KNOWN AS WRONG
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THIS
STATE. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ALLOWS THE NOTARY PUBLIC TO
REGISTER WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO PROVIDE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION CLARIFIED IN ONLINE
NOTE REPUBLIC MUST QUALIFY AS A
TRADITIONAL NOTARY UNDER
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES SECRETARY
. RULES SISTER TO IMPLEMENT THE
ACT BY JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AS SPECIFIES THIS
RULEMAKING PROCESS MUST ADDRESS
ISSUES SUCH AS ELECTRONIC
JOURNALS RETENTION AND STORAGE
OF RECORDS SCRUTINY AND
ENCRYPTION AND FEES THAT MAY BE
CHARGED BY AN ONLINE NOTARY
PUBLIC AND IT ONLINE NOTARY
PLATFORM AMONG OTHERS INSUREDS
COLLABORATION BY REQUIRING THE
SECRETARY OF STATE THE
CONSIDERED ABUSE OF STATE
ENTITIES DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES
AND THE PUBLIC AND DEVELOPING
THE RULES. CALIFORNIA NOTARY
SERVE AS A VITAL COMPONENT OF
EVERYDAY LIFE AND PERFORM
INVALUABLE SERVICES FOR BUSINESS
LEGAL FINANCIAL AND REAL ESTATE
COMMUNITIES A MONSTER COLBERT
NINETEEN A PANDEMIC NOTARY'S
PERFORMANCE SUCH A WORK ACROSS
OUR STATE TO ENSURE WE KEPT OUR
BUSINESS IS GROWING AS SUCH LAST
YEAR I INTRODUCED AB TEN NINETY
THREE TO CALIFORNIA NOTARY
PROTECTION ACT AS A WAY TO
ENSURE ACCESS AND PRESERVE THE
INTEGRITY. OF OUR NOTARY SYSTEM
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS I'VE
LEARNED HOW VITAL ACCESS TO
NOTARIES CARBON DAY LIFE AND
IT'S SUCH A NOTE SERVICES NOTARY
PUBLICS PERFORM DURING THE
PANDEMIC DESPONDENT CRISIS HAS
HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
MORE CONVENIENT ALTERNATIVE FOR
BOTH THOSE ACCESSING NOTARY.
SERVICES AND NOTARIES OF THE
SELVES COMMITTEE ON A PERSONAL
NOTE DURING THE PANDEMIC MY OWN.
WAS IN THE OFF. AND HE BEEN
SUSPENDED ADDED TO RESEARCH
PROBLEM. SHE WANTED TO LIVING
TRY. BUT BECAUSE THE RULES OF
THE HOSPITAL DOOR KOBE WE
COULDN'T BRING A NOTARY A
WITNESS FAMILY MEMBERS ALL LET
AT THE SAME TIME. IT BECAME VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US BECAUSE SHE
WANTED TO GET IT DONE BECAUSE
YOU WEREN'T SURE IF SHE WOULD
SURVIVE. THAT MADE IT CLEAR TO
ME THAT HAVING SOME KIND OF
REMOTE AXIS WOULD HAVE RESOLVED
THE PROBLEM NOT JUST MY MOTHER.
BEFORE PROBABLY EVERY CALIFORNIA
WHO'S BEEN GOING THROUGH COBIT
RIGHT NOW WHO ARE LYING IN STATE
IN HOSPITALS. MONOLITHS SERIOUS
CONDITION SHE'S ALL. SHE'S
HOPING WE'LL GET IT DONE. BUT I
JUST LAMENT ALL THE PROBLEMS
THAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED. TO ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO. WHOSE PARENT
PARENTS MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SURVIVE. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF HOW CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO ATTAIN. CRUCIAL
NOTARY SERVICES DURING A
PANDEMIC. THAT IS WHY MOVING RON
LEGISLATION IS VITAL. I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF STAFF THE
SPECIFICALLY JEFF. MEGA NATHAN
FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH ME IN
MY OFFICE ON THIS ISSUE. THIS
SEPARATE WHICH REQUIRED IT'S
DIFFERENT HAVE REQUIRED A GREAT
DEAL OF DISCUSSION AND
COLLABORATION. TO ADDRESS
VARIOUS PRIVACY AND
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS. OVERLAP
WE HAVE A- PART TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE FIRST OF A KIND.
RON FRAMEWORK THE BILL BEFORE
YOU IS THE PRODUCT OF A MONTHS
LONG STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
WORK IS NOT OVER. I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS. TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AS OUTLINED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AB
TEN NINETY THROUGH INCREASED
ACCESS TO VITAL MATERIAL
SERVICES IMPROVE PHYSICAL SAFETY
WHILE MAKING TRANSACTIONS AND
ENSURES CALIFORNIA. LEADS THE
WAY IN ADOPTING A SAFE AND
SECURE RONSON'S. CALIFORNIA
WOULD JOIN MORE THAN THIRTY
OTHER STATES THAT CURRENTLY
ALLOW VARIOUS FORMS OF REMOTE
ONLINE NOTED NOTED NOTARIZATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I HAVE YOU HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MATT
MILLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF INDEPENDENT NOTE HE'S-
AND I DON'T SALAS EACH YEAR.
VIDAK. SO HE'S USE. OUR GOAL
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NAME IS MILLER OF
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE GIVEN THE TEN
NOTARY AND I'M HERE TO REPRESENT
IN THE TEN NOTARIES ALL OVER THE
GOAL STATE- BEING ACTIVE ON THE
ISSUE OF REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION FOR MANY YEARS I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO TELL
YOU THAT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN NINETY THREE.
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS. FIRST
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND A TERREL
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS ALIKE.
BEGINNING WITH THE STATE OF
VIRGINIA TWENTY TWELVE SOME
THIRTY EIGHT STATES HAVE PASSED
REMOTE ONLINE NOTARIZATION AS
LEGISLATION TO DATE. AND
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
NOTARIES ARE EAGER TO EXPLORE
THE OPPORTUNITY OF JOINING THE
ONLINE NEUTRALIZATION WORLD.
SECOND AFTER MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS
OVER SEVERAL YEARS WE FINALLY
HAVE A BILL THAT OFFERS A SOLID
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMER DATA.
INCLUDING PERSONAL
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION THE
CONTENTS OF DOCUMENTS AND
TRANSACTIONAL RECORDS ALSO THIS
BILL WILL PROTECT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS FROM UNDUE LIABILITY
FROM BAD INDUSTRY ACTORS. AND AS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND OF BILLS
OFFERS A RESTITUTION MECHANISM
FOR INDIVIDUALS IN THE EVENT
THAT AN ONLINE NOTARY PLATFORM
VIOLATES PROVISIONS OF THIS.
PROPOSAL THAT RESULTS IN DAMAGES
TO THE PUBLIC. THIRD NO WILL
STRENGTHEN THEY ARE OFTEN A
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
REPUBLIC BY REQUIRING ALL NOTARY
ONLINE TO RE PLATFORMS ME
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE NEEDS
REQUIRES ALL PRACTITIONERS OF
TRAIN TRAINING- UNDERGO
EXAMINATION AND PURCHASE A BOND
AND REGISTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE BEFORE
OFFERING ONLINE NOTARY SERVICES
TO THE PUBLIC ULTIMATELY THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
NOTARIAL SYSTEM REMAINS AS
ROBUST AND RELIABLE AS IT IS
TODAY FOR MANY DECADES DECADES
TO COME AS A SUPPLEMENT JONES
SAWYER MENTIONED REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION IS A CONVENIENT
ALTERNATIVE TO A TRADITIONAL IN
PERSON NOTARIZATION FOR
BUSINESSES AND CLICK AND
CONSUMERS. BUT IS ESPECIALLY
BENEFICIAL TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE UNABLE TO EASILY
ACCESS NOTARIAL SERVICES WITH
ONGOING CONCERNS OF PANDEMIC AN
AGING POPULATION AND THE EVER
INCREASING DEMAND FOR NOTARIAL
SERVICES NOW IS THE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THIS INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
THIS BILL WILL SET A NEW
BENCHMARK IN THE REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION EXPERT CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
FOR THE REST OF THE REASONS
MENTIONED THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
INDEPENDENT NOTARIES- STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB TEN NINETY THREE
THERE- ON THE INTEREST PUBLIC
ACT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND WE KINDLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TEN NINETY THREE. RIGHT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE
OPERATE WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI TEN
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. YOU
HEAR AN INDICATION BEEN PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. BUT EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND WE WILL
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER WHEN
YOU'RE WE'RE READY TO OPEN. IF
USING A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET AND MAKE CERTAIN
THAT YOUR PHONE IS ON MUTE IT
BEFORE PRESSING ANY BUTTONS. WE
DO HAVE A LINE COMING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR LINE NUMBER THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
MARKETS REPRESENTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME MISTER SHERMAN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO WE DO HAVE A WITNESS ARE
YOU SPEAKING IN SUPPORT YES MY
NAME IS THERESA BRENNAN I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND A NOTARY AND I AM
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THERE ARE
ALSO SOME. WITH NOT NECESSARILY
OPPOSITION BUT CONCERNS THIS
WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE TIME FOR
THAT AS WELL IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR NOTE
CONCERNS. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU GO TO THE
ALLIANCE FOR. OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IT I IN OPPOSITION
OR HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT A. B. TEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
A LINE CUED UP WE'RE PROVIDING
THEIR LINE NUMBER RIGHT NOW ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE WILL OPEN UP
LINE TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF
OF DOCUSIGN WE MUST. AB CURRENT
OVER- ABOVE AND BEYOND EFFORT ON
THIS BILL BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT A COUPLE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
THEY PROCEED- AFTER TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WE WILL GO
. MY PARTY WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
MORE LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
I THINK WHAT THE LINE THIRTY
THREE. HI GOOD MORNING ANNA BACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS- WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS IT
STANDS- ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD
TO ALLOW THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND- WE- ARE.
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE BY- NOT ALLOWING-
NOTARIZATION- HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO BE AUTHORIZED- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. WHERE OF LINE
TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU ANTHONY HELTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PLANT BUT BASS
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS- STATED HERE BY- MY
COLLEAGUES- PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARD TO THE INTERSTATE
RECOGNITION OF PROVISIONS WITHIN
THE BILL- BUT ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO- REITERATE- TO START OUR
GRATITUDE THAT THE- YOU KNOW FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU COMMITTEE AND
THAT COMMITTEE STAFF INSURANCE.
AND AUTHOR OF PUT INTO THE- THIS
BILL SO FAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO WILL CONTINUE UNLESS YOU'RE
A- SORRY ARE THERE MORE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE ANY
DISCHARGED AS ELEVEN JUST AN
INDICATION OF. SUPPORT FORCE
SORRY INDICATION OF OPPOSITION
OR CONCERNS. MR GERETS MIKE
BULLARD I'M SORRY I MISSED BY A
QUEUE THERE AND I THOUGHT I
MIGHT SPEAK FOR JUST A MOMENT IF
I COULD. MISTER BELOW ALL RIGHT
. RIGHT SO I'M SPEAKING AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF A LARGE COALITION OF
BUSINESS GROUPS INCLUDING
MORTGAGE BANKERS AND CREDIT
UNIONS REALTORS LAND TITLE
NOTARY PLATFORMS INCLUDING
NOTARIZED AND DOCUSIGN THAT OUR
CLIENTS THE NATIONAL NOTARY
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA HAS
GROWN SO CA CAN. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
ESPECIALLY MISTER MAGNATES AND
PURCHASED A HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK
ON THIS BILL IS A DEDICATED
COUNTLESS HOURS TO LISTENING TO
THE VERY DISPARATE VIEWS
CRAFTING THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL AND CREATING A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE
NEITHER SUPPORTING NOR OPPOSING
THE BILL WE CERTAINLY AGREE IT'S
TIME TO JOIN THE DOZENS OF
STATES WHICH PERMIT RON I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT SOME ISSUES WHICH WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. SO ON A MACRO LEVEL OUR
CONCERNS RELATE TO INTERSTATE
RECOGNITION OF OUT OF STATE
NOTARIAL ACTS AND THE BREADTH OF
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
CONTAINED IN THE BILL. STATE
RECCA. WHISPER THORNY- ON THE
LEGAL FRONT RIGHT NOW. DOCUMENTS
THAT KNOWLEDGE TO OUT OF STATE
INCLUDING THOSE USING REMOTE
NOTARIZATION. ARE BEING RECORDED
IN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES PURSUANT
TO. CIVIL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE. IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL APPEARS TO
TAKE A STEP BACK FROM THIS. LONG
STANDING PRINCIPLE OF ACCEPTING
NOTARIAL ACTS PERFORMED IN OTHER
STATES. THAT IT WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA QUITE A DISTINCT OUT
LIAR IN THIS REGARD. WE'RE VERY
AFRAID THAT CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES WILL NOT BE SERVED BY
A POTENTIAL SUBSEQUENT
LITIGATION CHALLENGING THE
VALIDITY OF DOCUMENTS EXECUTED
OUT OF STATE. IN SOME CASES
THOSE DOCUMENTS MAY NOT BE
OPERATIVE UNTIL YEARS AFTER THEY
ARE EXECUTED. WE RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST IN
CONSUMER PROTECTION BUT WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS ISSUE
SHOULD BE RESOLVED AS THE BILL
PROCEEDS. AND ON THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THAT OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED. WE THINK THE LANGUAGE
SHOULD BE MORE NARROWLY CRAFTED
ON ISSUES SUCH AS WHO HAS
STANDING TO SUE AND RELATING
DAMAGES TO HARM. THERE ARE MORE
TECHNICAL- TARGETED ISSUES SUCH
AS NOTARY EDUCATION FUNDING AND
NO TO RETURN HOLES WHICH WE
BELIEVE CAN BE ADDRESSED AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. AGAIN WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
STAFF ESPECIALLY MISTER MAGNATE
AND ESPECIALLY MISTER JONES
SAWYER FOR HIS HARD WORK ON THIS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND THANK YOU FOR. LISTENING
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ANYONE LSE
WITH OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS BUT
WE WILL. NOT BE TAKING TESTIMONY
JUST AN INDICATION OF.
OPPOSITION CONCERNS OR EVEN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
LINE CUED UP IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE THAT. WE WERE LINE THIRTY
FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. I CHAIR
THE THROUGH THE- NOT REBEL BUT
MCAFEE FIFTIETH BIRTHDAY
NOTARIZED BY COMBINE OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY- AND
THEN NAY AND MICHAELA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIRD OVER THE LINES
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL THEN.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER JOHN SORRY WANTED THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THIS ON THE
SUSPEND A SEVERAL YEAR JOURNEY
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON. AND I THINK IT IS
DEFINITELY TIME THAT CALIFORNIA
TAKE ON THE REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO
CAREFULLY I KNOW A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE IT BUT
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG HAD. A
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR NOTORIOUS
SERVICES AND APPROPRIATELY
DIFFERENT SANDERS IT IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE PROTECTIVE OF CONSUMERS
AND THAT HAS SURVIVED SCRUTINY
IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IT WE ARE JUST INTENDING
WITH THIS BILL TO CONTINUE THAT
HIGH LEVEL OF PROTECTION FOR
CONSUMERS OF SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED. I CANNOT REALLY
AGREE WITH AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU CAN READ
THIS IN THE ANALYSIS AS WELL.
THAT WE ARE NOT TAKING A STEP
BACKWARD IN IN FACT REALIGNING
OURSELVES WITH WHAT OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE AT A LOWER LEVEL OF
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS THAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. THERE
ARE. PROBABLY SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT THAT CAN BE RESOLVED
OVER TIME. AS THIS WORKS THROUGH
ITS PROCESS. AND SOME PRACTICAL
IMPLICATIONS OF COMMUNICATIONS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE
HAVE. THE ABILITY TO RECOGNIZE
APPROPRIATE OUT OF STATE.
NOTARIZATION AND MANAGE THE
DOCUMENTS FROM THAT SO THAT I
THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS TO
WORK ON BUT I'M- FOR ME I'M
HAPPY WITH THE STATE OF THE BILL
RIGHT NOW. I THINK IT IS WORTHY
OF. MOVING OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE DO
AND IF WE DON'T THEN IT AT.
THAT'S POTENTIALLY ANOTHER SET
BACK AND THAT IN GETTING
CALIFORNIA TODAY TO SET A BETTER
STANDARD FOR REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZATION AN AWFULLY OTHER
STATES WILL. SHIFT AND FOLLOW
OUR LEAD I THINK MORE
APPROPRIATELY. GIVEN WHAT WE DO
SO I THINK YOU YOU HAVE DONE
YEOMAN'S WORK ON THIS MISTER
JONES SAWYER. AND WITH YOUR
PERSONAL STORIES WELL.
ILLUSTRATES THE NEED AND NOT
JUST DURING A PANDEMIC BUT
OVERALL PEOPLE ARE MOVING ONLINE
AND HAVE EXPECTATIONS FOR VERY
SERVICES ONLINE. SO I THINK
THAT'S- APPROPRIATE THE WAY TO
GO AND MISTER MEG ATHENS.
ANALYSIS REALLY POINTS TO THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
BOTH BY SUPPORTERS AND BY
OPPOSITIONS AND SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT THAT WE MAY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON BUT I THINK
THIS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE
THOUGH. AND I'M HAPPY THAT IT IS
MOVING ON TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND I'M HOPING WE
CAN MOVE THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR
AND THEN OFF TO THE SENATE. SO
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
DISCOGRAPHY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK IT'S VERY MUCH NEEDED-
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE'VE HAVE
REMOTE ONLINE NOTARY- HAVE TO
LONG IN THE IN THE MAKING I'M
SURE- AS SO I APPRECIATE HIS HIS
HARD WORK ON THIS- WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT. IS THAT THIS
ACTUALLY MAY WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE WITHOUT DOING SOME
TWEAKS. COULD ACTUALLY
DISCOURAGE THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY- AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO
USE REMOTE ONLINE NOTARY. AND
HERE'S WHAT I'M YEAH MR BELOW I
THINK PRETTY APTLY OINTED OUT
SOME OF THOSE THINGS ONE IS. WE
ARE KIND OF STAND IN THE FACE OF
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE
THAT ALLOWS. YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT WERE DONE IN OTHER STATES
TO BE RECOGNIZED- IN CALIFORNIA
AND IN FACT WE ALREADY DO THIS-
WHEN PEOPLE WHEN PEOPLE.
NOTARIZE DOCUMENTS OUT OF STATE.
WE ACCEPT THOSE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN A VALID NOTARIZATION OF
SAID DEED. FOR INSTANCE- SO I
DON'T SEE WHY WE WOULD NOT DO
THAT IN THIS CASE WHEN SOMEBODY
DOES USES REMOTE ONLINE NOTARY.
TECHNOLOGY OUT OF STATE- TO ALSO
FULLY ACCEPT THAT IN CALIFORNIA-
THE OTHER PROBLEM IS. THE
OPENING OF THIS BROUGHT PRIVATE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION- THAT
WILL MAYBE DISCOURAGE PEOPLE
FROM UTILIZING THIS IF THEY KNOW
THE A ONE. ONE MISTAKE ONE- YOU
KNOW NOT FOLLOWING ONE IOTA OF
THE OF THE LAW SUBJECTS YOU TO
BROAD. LITIGATION AND LIABILITY-
WE MAY HAVE A LOT ACTORS WHO
WON'T DECIDE TO DO REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARY SERVICES- IN CALIFORNIA
SO I THINK BOTH OF THOSE THINGS
COULD BE AN IMPEDIMENT. AND
THAT'S OF CONCERN THERE COULD BE
IMPEDIMENT TO US UTILIZING WHAT
I THINK WE ALL AGREE IS WHAT WE-
WILL MORE OF THIS MORE
AVAILABILITY OF THIS- IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN LASTLY. I
THINK IT COULD ACTUALLY BE A
REALLY BIG IMPEDIMENT TO
CONSUMERS AND I'LL I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW I THINK THIS
COULD. HURT CONSUMERS- YOU I
HAVE AN OUT OF STATE LANDOWNERS
. IN CALIFORNIA WHO NOTARIZE IS
A DEED SELLING IT TO A CONSUMER
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHO WHO WHO
BUYS THAT PROPERTY- AND THAT IS
DONE OUT OF STATE AND- BY REMOTE
ONLINE NOTARY AND YEARS LATER
SOMEONE COULD COME BACK AND SAY
TO THAT CONSUMER HEY THAT WASN'T
DONE. IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF CALIFORNIA LAW
THAT'S THAT'S VOID. THAT DATE IS
NO GOOD THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM FOR
CONSUMERS IF THEY CAN'T HAVE
TRUST IN THE FACT THAT WHEN
SOMETHING IS SOLD TO THEM AND
THEY UTILIZE YOU KNOW REMOTE
ONLINE NOTARY THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A VALID- RECORDING
AND GIVE THEM TITLE TO PROPERTY-
SO THAT IS A REALLY BIG PROBLEM
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT AND
I THINK IT'S IT REALLY ISN'T A
BIG CHANGE THIS IS RECOGNIZING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW.
REMOTE ONLINE NOTARY THIS DONE
OTHER STATES TO BERECOGNIZED IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL- AND IT'S NOT
LIKE THE STATE'S A REALLY LACKS
PROTECTIONS. I REALLY DON'T
EVERY SAY THIS DONE THIS HAS
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT. THE PEOPLE HAT ARE DOING
THIS ARE WHO THEY SAY THEY ARE.
FACT THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
HAVING A NOTARY IN THE FIRST
PLACE IS THAT YOU APPEAR. YOU
CAN BE FOR THE PAIR BEFORE THE
NOTARY PHYSICALLY. OR YOU CAN DO
IT IN THE DIGITAL WORLD. ONLINE
AND THEY ENSURE THAT YOU ARE IN
FACT TO YOU SAY YOU ARE IN THIS
IS YOUR SIGNATURE. AND AUTHENTIC
TO AUTHENTICATE THE DOCUMENT- SO
I DON'T THINK THERE REALLY IS
ANY CONCERN ABOUT OTHER STATES.
YOU KNOW SOMEHOW ALLOWING FOR
FRAUDULENT DOCUMENTS TO BE
RECORDED THEY HAVE PROTECTIONS
AS WELL- IN PLACE SO. I WOULD
REALLY HELP ME MAKE THAT CHANGE
WE GO FOR A REALLY I WANT TO. BE
SUPPORTER OF BRINGING THIS
ONLINE BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE AUTHOR WOULD
ENTERTAIN MAKING THOSE THOSE
CHANGES TO JUST MAKE SURE THIS
IS GONNA BE IS BROADLY
AVAILABLE. AS POSSIBLE TO
CONSUMERS WHICH IS WHAT I THINK-
WE ALL WANT. THREE THANK YOU
GERMAN BUT I DID WANT TO SAY.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WAS DONE ON THIS- I THINK
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS. AND THIS IS A LOT OF
HARD WORK AND EVEN SPEAKING WITH
AND HEARING THE OPPOSITION TODAY
IT'S CLEAR THAT WE'RE ON THAT
PATH THAT THIS WASN'T SOMETHING
THAT WAS DONE BY ONE GROUP AND
THAT'S THE END OF IT THIS WAS
ABSOLUTE COLLABORATION AND I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WAS DONE IN THAT REGARD- I THINK
THAT. AS A CHAIR HAS MENTIONED
THE PROTECTION OF THE CONSUMER
IS AT THE TOP OF THE LIST
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK TO
US TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
POLICY WE DO PASS PROTECTS THE
CONSUMER. AND IT'S MUCH EASIER
FOR NO REASON THAN TO FOLLOW
WHATEVER THE POLICY IS BUT OUR
CONSUMERS RELY ON US TO PROVIDE
THAT PROTECTION BUT JUST IN
REVIEWING THE VERY EXTENSIVE-
ANALYSIS AND IN SPEAKING WITH-
THOSE IN SUPPORT IN THOSE WITH
CONCERNS IT'S CLEAR THAT A LOT
OF WORK HAS GONE INTO THIS AND-
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS THE WAY
POLICY SHOULD BE DONE. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MR. THANK YOU- I HAVE
TO START OUT WITH COMPLETELY
AGREE I HAD TO DO THREE NOTARIES
THIS YEAR- IN REGARDS TO- REAL
ESTATE. AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
ONLINE WOULD BE A LOT EASIER DUE
TO THE FACT THAT- WITH COLD IN
THERE TRYING TO HAVE SOMEONE
COME TO YOUR HOUSE AND GOING
SOMEWHERE. HOWEVER I DO HAVE THE
CONCERNED- THAT SOME OF THE
OTHERS HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT. AND SO
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS.
BASICALLY NOT VOTE AT THIS POINT
BUT I WANT TO THIS CONCERNS
ADDRESSED- BECAUSE I DO THINK
IT'S A GREAT HELP I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THOSE. ITEMS ARE TAKEN
CARE OF SO THAT WAY I CAN FEEL A
100% THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
BENEFITING EVERYBODY. BUT THANK
YOU FOR THIS BILL WILL. THANK
YOU NO ONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT
RESERVED JONES SAWYER YOU MAY
CLOSE AT NIGHT I WANT TO THANK
YOU NOT AND I WISH THAT THIS-
COMMITTEE OR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COULD HAVE BEEN AT SOME OF OUR
MEETINGS- THAT WE'VE HAD ON THIS
BILL OF NOT ONLY WAS A
COLLABORATIVE BUT- WHAT DO YOU
FOR OR AGAINST IT WHEN YOU HAD A
SPECIFIC CONCERN. EVERYBODY HAD
INPUT AND EVERYBODY EQUAL INPUT
AND WE TOOK EVERYONE'S CONCERNS
ON THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY ON OUT
OF STATE- ARE PROBABLY AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST. FOR BOTH SIDES
THAT WE NEED TO TRY TO WORK
THROUGH THAT- IT IT AND SO I I'D
MAKE A COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL-
TO THOSE OTHER FORWARD AND IT
NAY DEFICIT BECAUSE THIS NEEDS
TO MOVE FORWARD ANYTHING TO GET
DONE- WHAT THANK MR GALLAGHER
FOR ADDING ANOTHER. SHE APPROACH
ABOUT TO DEPICTING I NEED TO
WORK ON- AND YOU BROUGHT UP
ANOTHER POINT THAT I WILL. I
WILL TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
AND- I WORK ON MAKING SURE THAT
IT DOESN'T INHIBIT CONSUMERS
FROM FROM UNIT AND SO FAR. I
HEAR EVERYONE LOUD AND CLEARLY.
AND AS YOU LISTEN TO EVEN THE
OPPOSITION HOPEFULLY YOU HEARD.
THAT I AM WILLING TO TRY TO WORK
THROUGH AS MANY POSITIONS AS AS
POSSIBLE- BUT FROM BUT FOR ME
HERE'S MY BET. IS THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TO IMPLEMENT THAT. THIS
DISTINCT THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. ALSO
NEED TO OPEN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT THIS INSIGHT. I
VALUE THEIR INPUT ALSO. ON FIFTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BELIEVES THIS
IS CONSTITUTIONAL WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THESE PROTECTIONS- HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE'S. WE CAN BRING OUR
BRING EVERYONE IN A ROOM SO WE
CAN TRY TO HASH THAT OUT. ON
THE- OF PRIVACY RIGHT ACTION AND
THEN ON THE OTHER STATE THAT'S
THE SECRETARY STATE WHO HAS TO-
REALLY. AUTHORIZED PEOPLE BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND WE HAVE TO
LISTEN TO THEM AND- BASICALLY
THERE ARE FOR CALI. AND THEY NOW
HAVE THIS OFF JOB NOW AND WE
WERE SHOULD. MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T INHIBIT THEM FROM BEING
ABLE TO DO THEIR JOBS PROPERLY.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU FIRST WE DO
HAVE A PORCH WITH THE STATUS QUO
STONE HERE GALLAGHER. HELLO HERE
BENNETT BONTA. YOU'RE FREE
FIFTIES KALRA. KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES YOUR WICKS. THANK YOU NOW
I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON A. B.
TEN NINETY THREE THAT MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND. I CAN ADD A SECOND
THANK YOU SO MUCH KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER
YEAH BASED ON THE COMMITMENT OF
THE AUTHOR. WHO I KNOW WORKS ON
THESE THINGS AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BENNETT. BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
DAVIES. KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES
REYES AYE WICKS. THAT BILL IS
OUT OF THANK YOU THANK YOU
COMMITTEE. MISTER RODRIGUEZ ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. FOURTEEN. THE
NEW YORK WHEN YOU HAVE A KNACK.
FOR WARD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THIS BILL IS THE RESULT
OF CONVERSATION I'VE HAD WITH
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN HOMEOWNER
RIGHTS AND SOME HOME OWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS. BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WORKING OVER THE
INTERMITTENT A ON THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THIS BILL AS WELL AS
PENDING CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
THAT ADDRESS NOTE ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. SB FOURTEEN
TENCENT SIX PROTECT HOMEOWNER
RIGHT BY FIRST ENSURING THOSE IN
CHARGE OF A CHOICE HAVE PROPER
ETHICS AND HARASSMENT TRAINING.
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BURL
STUDY HAS SHOWN THAT A TREE
BOARD MEMBERS ARE LARGELY
UNAWARE OF PRODUZIERT AND
ETHICAL RESPONSIBILITIES.
VALUENGINE OF THESE LAWS COST
HOMEOWNER HR HOMEOWNERS. MONEY
WHEN A BOARD MEMBER OR STAFF
VIOLATES THE LAW. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PLYMOUTH ARE CONCERNED
THAT REQUIREMENT AT THE KEY
TRAINING WOULD DETER HOMEOWNER
FROM RUNNING FOR THEIR EIGHT
CHOI REPORTS HOWEVER THAT DOES
NOT APPEAR SO IN OTHER EXISTING
CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS COACHING.
THAT SAID I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION. NEXT MY
BILL ADDRESSES SOMETHING THAT
HAS HAPPENED DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND NATURAL DISASTERS.
HOMEOWNERS IN MY DISTRICT AND
BEYOND MY DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
CHARGED FOR MINOR VIOLATIONS
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN QUARANTINED
AND EVACUATED DURING STATES
RUMORED HE'S- THIS BILL IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO UPHOLD
HUMAN RIGHTS PROTECT ALL PARTIES
FROM HARM. RESPECT ACT FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU IN MISSOURI
BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED THE
AMENDMENTS YOU ARE TAKING THOSE
MOMENTS AS PRESIDENT CORRECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT YOUR
FIRST WITNESS- WITNESSED IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TEN.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS. OPERATE
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES FOR AB FOURTEEN TO. IN
TO SPEAKER- OF THE INSTANCES OF
SIR IS THAT CORRECT YES. THE
EIGHT DENTIST BEACON SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN TEN PRESS ONE THEN-ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. DETERMINE WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN TEN. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN TEN. IT IS BEACON
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN TEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETEEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR LOUIS BROWN
CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE FIRST LET ME EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
OUR PARTNERSHIP IN THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
MEETING WITH US ON OUR CONCERNS-
WE DO STILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED ALTHOUGH THE MAINTENANCE
DO- OF THE BILL IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- I JUST LIKE TO RAISE
TWO LARGER CONCERNS- AS WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE
ISSUES DEALING. WITH H. AWAY- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT EVERY TIME WE AT A COST-
THOSE COSTS FORTY WE GET BORN BY
THE HOMEOWNERS WITHIN A AND H.
AWAY- HOAS ARE PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS NONPROFIT.
CORPORATIONS THAT OPERATE ON
ZERO BASED BUDGET SPEND ANYTIME
WE INCREASE THOSE COSTS BROGLIE
BORN BY- THE HOMEOWNERS THROUGH
INCREASED SEVERANCE WE LOOK AT
SOMETHING LIKE MANDATORY
TRAINING OR EDUCATION OR BOARD
MEMBERS ARE WE ARE CONCERNED
BECAUSE ON ANY GIVEN DAY WE DO I
FIND IT VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND
BOARD MEMBERS TO RUN FOR THE
POSITION WE BELIEVE THAT YOU
JUST. ADD NEW REQUIREMENTS
ACOSTA THAT IT'LL MAKE IT THAT
MUCH MORE DFFICULT SO WHAT WILL
LIKELY HAPPEN IN THE ACTIVITY
WHICH IS THE ASSOCIATION WILL
BEAR THOSE COSTS. IN ORDER TO-
MAKE IT AGAIN AS APPEALING AS
POSSIBLE AFTER SOMEONE TO ASSUME
THIS RESPONSIBILITY. AND THEN
THAT JUST ADDS TO THE COST OF
THIS AN OLD LEE BORN OUT BY THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WE LIKE TO TRY TO
WORK WITH YOU THE AUTHOR TO FIND
THE MIDDLE GROUND- ON THAT TYPE
OF ISSUE- AND THEN AS IT GOES
WITH OF RESTRICTING WHAT'S SO IF
YOU CAN DO. YOU CAN REACH SPEEDS
THEY COPY OF THE DNR'S THEY FIND
THAT THEY RECEIVED A COPY AND
THAT THEY'VE READ A COPY OF THE
SPEECH IN ARE THEY KNOW THE
RULES COMING INTO AN ASSOCIATION
WHEN THEY BUY INTO AN
ASSOCIATION SO WE START TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THE T. EIGHTEEN R.
FOR WE PROHIBIT SPECIFIC
SECTIONS OF TEACHING ART. WE ARE
CHANGING THE CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH ALL MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION SO WHILE WE TRY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES OF
A FEW- BECAUSE OF COVENANTS OR
RESTRICTIONS IN THEIR IN THEIR-
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE WITHIN THE BILL
REGARDING ROOMMATES ARE LONG
TERM LODGERS. THAT HAS OTHER
ISSUES INCREASE OTHER ISSUES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE ASSOCIATION SO
THERE ARE ALREADY PROCESS IN
PLACE TO CHANGE THE CPR'S HOW TO
CHANGE THE RULES- THAT AN
ASSOCIATION ABIDES BY OR THAT
PEOPLE BUY INTO AND SO WE ASK
THAT. YOU KNOW WE'D BE VERY
CAREFUL AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT YOU NEED TO BUILD
THAT SEEK TO LIMIT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN ASSOCIATION
TO HAVE RULES THAT PEOPLE OF
BODY INTO AND THAT PEOPLE OF
FIVE. TO WITHOUT WE WILL ASK FOR
A NO VOTE TODAY BUT DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IF THE BILL MOVES TO
CONTINUE TO REFINE THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S IN THE AMENDMENTS AND SEE
IF WE CAN REACH COMMON. GROUND
THANK YOU. THANK AND WE OFFER A
LINED MINUTES OPERATOR WELL I
THINK I BELIEVE WE HAVE A WOODEN
IN. ROGER US WHO PROBABLY CALLED
IN ON A NOTE IS HE AVAILABLE. BY
BYE DO NOT WE DO NOT. GATHER THE
NAMES OF THOSE SELLING IN EXCESS
AND LYFT THEY'RE DIALING IN HAS
A AS A WITNESS AHEAD OF TIME.
I'M NOT SEEING THAT NAME ON HERE
. OKAY SO LET'S DOUBLE CHECK ONE
MOMENT PLEASE DOUBLE CHECK AND
THEN PROCEED TO HELP BY I DO NOT
SEE THAT THEY APPEAR AT ALL SO I
I'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP LINE
TEN. GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS TOM FREELY I'M THE CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS. WITH
PERSONALLY OVER THIRTY YEARS OF
HANDS ON C. ID MANAGEMENT
EXPERIENCE. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN TEN. WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
AGREED TO BY THE AUTHOR AND
PRESSURED TO WORK AND INTENTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF. THEY GO A LONG WAY IN
IMPROVING THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IMPOSING
FORMAL TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ON
VOLUNTEER HOMEOWNERS HAS
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS ALREADY
STRUGGLE TO FIND PEOPLE TO SERVE
ON A CHILLY BOARDS. WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT ANY RESULTING
INCREASE COSTS OF ASSOCIATIONS
WILL RESULT IN INCREASED
HOMEOWNER ASSESSMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE BELIEVE MORE
CLARIFICATION IS NEEDED IN THE
BILL TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE NO
CANAD CERTAIN CONSEQUENCES TO AN
HOAS ABILITY TO REGULATE SHORT
TERM RENTALS CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING LAW. TO ENFORCE
RESTRICTIONS IN SITUATIONS WHERE
HOMEOWNER HAS A LARGER. AND TO
ENFORCE VIOLATIONS THAT ARE NOT
DUE TO OR IMPACTED BY A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE BUT WITH AT THIS
TIME WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY N. EVEN THE SUPPORT
WHEN THIS MAY HAVE CALLED IN ON
A DIFFERENT LINE. YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYONE ELSE CALLING IN. HE
CALLED IN ON IT ON EITHER ONE OF
THEM THE BLINDS THAT WERE
ASSIGNED TO THIS CONFERENCE CALL
WE WOULD HAVE THEM EITHER IN HAS
A AS A AS A WITNESS WHAT WE HAVE
THEIR NAME OR HAS A CURTIS SPENT
THAT CAN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
OKAY. SO I GUESS HE DIDN'T
COLONIZE- SERVICE RODRIGUEZ
THAT'S FINE OKAY- THANK YOU SO
WE'VE HAD TEN OPERATOR THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE ON THE LINES. JUST
DOUBLE CHECKING. THAT'S CORRECT
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. AUSTIN'S COMMENTS
DAVIES THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I'VE I'VE HAD THIS
EXPERIENCE I SERVED TEN YEARS ON
MY H. AWAY AND SERVED AS
PRESIDENT AND I THINK THAT IS
ONE OF MY CONCERNS LAST YEAR
RAND AB FIVE A TO. ME ONLY TO BE
ABLE TO. MAKE I EASIER TO
RECOLLECT BOARD MEMBERS BECAUSE
THERE IS NO BOARD MEMBERS AND I
TEND TO JOKES SOMETIMES AS I HAD
A RUN FOR SOMETHING TO GET OFF
MY BOARD. AND- AND SO THAT'S
WHERE I'M HERE ABOUT THEM THAT
IS A CONCERN ESPECIALLY WITH-
INFLATION IN THE PRICES OF-
HOUSING GOING UP IS THAT- IF
THERE'S A COST I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T COST MAIN BIT
MINIMUM BUT- IF IT GOES BACK TO
THE- H. AWAY. MANAGEMENT TEAM
EVENTUALLY IT'S GOING TO GO BACK
WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR CONTRACT
THE NEXT YEAR AND IS GOING TO
COME BACK TO THEM AND I KNOW
THAT WE'VE- I WAS GIVEN
DIFFERENT TRAINING OPTIONS AND
OVER THE YEARS I'VE ALWAYS ASKED
HAS ANYONE EVER PICK THEM UP AND
THEY HAVEN'T. SO THE I THINK
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS- THAT IS
GOING TO- EVEN PUSH BACK MORE
AND TRYING TO GET GOOD QUALIFIED
PEOPLE TO COME AS ALSO TAKING
USUALLY IF YOU'RE DOING AN
ETHICS CLASS THAT COULD BE A
THREE HOUR ETHICS CLASS AND THAT
MAY NOT SOUND LIKE A LOT. BUT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE BUSY IT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT JUST TO
TEAR THEM SO. AT THIS TIME GOING
TO VOTE NO BUT IF THERE'S THINGS
YOU CAN WORK OUT- THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. DEFTLY OFFICE. ON THE TOP
OF HER. LIKE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
FOR. AND ALSO. WE'RE BE THERE
THE BEGINNING BUT THIS. THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS SO I'M
OPEN TO THAT. BUT JUST ONE THING
I WANTED. TO REITERATE TO YOU
TALK ABOUT THE INCREASED COST IF
WE WERE TO- MAKE THIS ADDITIONAL
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. BUT I
LOOK AT IT IS. YEAH MAYBE. IT
MAY BE A SMALL INVESTMENT
BECAUSE SAY IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THIS TRAINING. EDUCATION
REGARDING. ETHICS AND
HARASSMENT. AT THAT AGE WHITE
FACE TO THE LAWSUIT. THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY. A LOT OF MONEY
OUT. THIS LOOK TO PREVENT THAT
RIGHT SO. WHO'S TO SAY THAT OKAY
THIS YEAR. WE HAVE TWO OR THREE
LAWSUITS BECAUSE- FOLKS WERE
HARASSED. OR INTIMIDATED OR
WHATEVER WANT TO CALL IT. BUT
MAYBE COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
IF THAT TRAINING SO WHO'S TO SAY
THAT. BECAUSE THE LOSS IS NOT
WORKING WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO RAISE IT. NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
TO COVER THIS ADDITIONAL COST
SO. I LOOK AT THIS BILL AS A
PREVENTATIVE MEASURE. TO HELP
PROTECT THE HOMEOWNERS.
ASSOCIATION FROM ANY FUTURE
LAWSUITS BECAUSE TECHNICALLY.
WHY NOT OUR BOARD MEMBERS WERE
EDUCATED AND TRAINED IN THIS SO-
THEY HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF NOT
. THE HAVING THESE ISSUES HAPPEN
OUR TO. SO JUST CONFIRM FOR. I
THINK IT'S- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. COMMENTS IT WAS
RODRIGUEZ OR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK IT IS ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE I'VE INTERACTED WITH
A NUMBER OF HOAS THROUGHOUT BY
MY LIFE IT AND OFTEN TIMES
THEY'RE VERY FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
IT IS A LOT- OFTEN THE SAME
PEOPLE AND I DO UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY IN.
IN RECRUITING BUT- OFTENTIMES
THE SAME PEOPLE WITH WITHOUT THE
SOPHISTICATION OF DEALING WITH.
LOTS OF MONEY. AND NOT VERY
CLEAR ON THEIR ETHICAL
OBLIGATIONS AND THESE ARE
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS. BUT IN A
WAY THEY THEY OPERATE. I THINK
AS WE WOULD EXPECT A PUBLIC.
BODY TO OPERATE BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE LIVING AND PAYING DUES
AND THEN AND BEING SUBJECTED TO
THAT THE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
. OR MORE LIKE THE PUBLIC
ESPECIALLY IN LARGE COMPLEXES
WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
SO FOR NOT WILLING TO SET AN
APPROPRIATE STANDARD THEN THERE
IS A LOT OF MISCHIEF THAT CAN
HAPPEN AND IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND EVERYONE WHO IS
PARTICIPATING IN IT TAT THE-
THE THOSE OFFICERS ARE TRAINED
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THICAL
OBLIGATIONS AND I DO AGREE WITH
YOU THAT IT WILL SAVE A LOT OF
GRIEF AND MONEY. DOWN THE LINE
TO GO AHEAD WITH THAT STEP SO I
THINK IT'S A VERY APPROPRIATE
BILL. RIGHT AND WITH THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE. WHAT THE RESTRICTIONS
RIVAL THANK YOU OKAY SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE THIS RODRIGUEZ. PERFECT
REACTOR ABOUT THINKING THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. NOW GALLAGHER NO.
SENATE BONTA BONTA I DAVIS DAVIS
NO KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
NO MAIENSCHEIN REYES FIVE REYES
AYE WICKS. THE BILL NEEDS TO
MORE SO WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MS BIRKHEAD
ALL OF NUMBER FOUR HR. SEVENTY
EIGHT. FINE OKAY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- IT'S GOOD TO
BE WITH YOU THIS MORNING AS I
WAS THINKING ABOUT PRESENTING
THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE YOU TODAY
I REALIZE THAT MY ENTIRE LIFE I
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE GRANTED IN
ROE V. WADE I GIVEN BIRTH THREE
TIMES HAD THREE LIVE BIRTHS FIVE
THREE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN. BUT ON
MY JOURNEY TO BECOMING A MOTHER
AT EVERY MOMENT IT WAS MY
DECISION MY DECISION WHAT TO DO
MY DECISION WHETHER TO HAVE THAT
CHILD. AND THE FACT TODAY WE'RE
LOOKING AT REMARKING ON THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE
V. WADE WHICH GUARANTEED WOMEN
THAT RIGHT TO PRIVACY. AND WE
MAY NOT MAKE IT TO THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY. WITH ROE V. WADE
INTACT. WITH THAT RIGHT TO
PRIVACY IT SAYS THAT THE
DECISION. THAT A WOMAN MAKES
ABOUT HER OWN BODY IS BETWEEN
HER HER HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
AND WHOEVER SHE CHOOSES TO MAKE
THAT DECISION WITH. I CAN THINK
OF NOTHING MORE PRIVATE. THAN
THOSE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
WITH YOUR HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
ABOUT WHAT YOU DO WITH YOUR OWN
BODY AND THAT IS WHAT ROW GAVE
TO WOMEN. GAVE WOMEN HARD FOUGHT
EQUITY. THAT WE KNOW MAYBE
TURNED BACKWARDS IF THE SUPREME
COURT. OVERTURNS OR TAKES AWAY
SOME OF THE RIGHTS GUARANTEED IN
ROUTE. AND WE KNOW THAT STATES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE WORKING
TO TAKE THAT RIGHT AWAY. TWENTY
SIX STATES ARE POISED TO BAN
ABORTION ACCESS IF ROE V. WADE
IS OVERTURNED NO AFFECTS THIRTY
SIX MILLION WOMEN. THIS IS BEEN
THE WORST YEAR IN HISTORY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PROTECTIONS IN
ROE V. WADE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SIX ABORTION RESTRICTIONS HAVE
BEEN ENACTED NINETEEN STATES
INCLUDING TWELVE ABORTION BANS.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TODAY
BY SAYING THE CALIFORNIA ASKS
CONGRESS TO. MAKE A STATEMENT
SUPPORTING ABORTION AND
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IS CRITICAL TO THE
FIGHT THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WE HAVE MOLLY ROBSON FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD ON THE PHONE
. THANK YOU. SO WE I GUESS TO
HAVE ONE WITNESS ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THE FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
. MY REFERENCE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES IN THE STATE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE- IN OVER A
HUNDRED HEALTH CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AT FIRST
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAND FOR HER
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITY
RESOLUTION TO CELEBRATE THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HISTORIC ROE V. WADE SUPREME
COURT DECISION WHICH PROTECTS
THE RIGHT TO ABORTION IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE CELEBRATE THE
SANTA EVER YEAR BOB THIS YEAR IS
A LITTLE DIFFERENT AS THIS YEAR
THERE THE CASE CURRENTLY BEFORE
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT THAT
DIRECTLY CHALLENGES THE LEGAL
PROTECTION CRAFTED ROUTE.
PENDING A DECISION FROM THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED TWENTY SIX
STATES ARE LIKELY TO BAN OR
SEVERELY RESTRICT ABORTION. THE
BACK HALF OF THE STATES IN THE
UNITED STATES WOULD LOSE ACCESS
TO ABORTION IMPACTING THIRTY SIX
MILLION WOMEN AND MORE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CAPABLE OF BECOMING
PREGNANT. ROBI LATEST OFF THE
FLOOR AND WE'RE FORTUNATE TO BE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH LEADERS WHO
STAND WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
ORGANIZATION I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT ABORTION IS HEALTH CARE AND
ANYTHING LESS THAN EQUITABLE
ACCESS WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. SHE
DOES NOT FOR ACCESS TO CARE AND
THOSE IN RURAL AREAS OF OUR
STATE. WE WILL NOT STOP FIGHTING
TO PROTECT THE RIGHT TO ABORTION
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
EXPAND ACCESS NOT A FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT ALSO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE GOING TO BE FOR FIFTY
CARE HERE. THANK YOU A FAMILY
MEMBER CLEARLY ACCEPTED FOR
BRINGING AWARENESS TO THIS
RESOLUTION PLANTAGENETS PROPERTY
OR H. R. SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. RIGHT THE OTHER ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY ON THE PHONES IN
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY EIGHT.
OPERATOR YOU CAN SUPPORT OF IT.
BECAUSE BECAUSE SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUEDUP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR HR SEVENTY EIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF H. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN
ARNOLD. I'M A MOTHER OF SEVEN.
AND AN ATTORNEY. I AM ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF OUTREACH AT THE
RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE AMERICA'S
FIRST PRO LIFE ORGANIZATION
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
PRESUME YOU KNOW THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY MADE ABORTION
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA FIFTY FIVE
YEARS AGO SIX YEARS BEFORE ROE
VERSUS WADE. THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN JOBS WILL LIKELY
SEND THE ISSUE BACK TO THE
STATES HAVING NO IMPACT
WHATSOEVER ON ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA. H. R. SEVENTY EIGHT
IS YOUR RESPONSIBLE VIRTUE
SIGNALING. THANKS TO BIDEN'S
BLUE STATE BAILOUT CALIFORNIA
NOW HAS A WHOPPING THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR STATE SURPLUS AND
ARE SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
TONI ATKINS ALREADY WANTS TO USE
THIS SURPLUS TO PAY THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
SANCTUARY ABORTION HUB OF THE
NATION. PAYING TO FLY WOMEN TO
CALIFORNIA TO GET FREE ABORTIONS
HERE SUBSIDIZING THEIR LODGING
HERE AND YES EVEN THEIR CHILD
CARE HERE WHILE THEY'RE GETTING
FREE ABORTIONS. THIS IS INSANITY
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DO NOT
WANT TO BANK ROLL EVERY ABORTION
IN THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIANS ARE
FLEEING THE STATE WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST TAX RATE IN THE COUNTRY
HOUSING IS TOTALLY UNAFFORDABLE
FOR MANY BUSINESSES ARE SHUTTING
DOWN OR LEAVING ORGANIZE SMASH
AND GRAB GANGS ARE TERRORIZING
SHOPPERS WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
POLICE TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS ARE IN
EVERY CITY UNDER FREEWAYS AND
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
FAILING OUR CHILDREN THURMOND
WOULD YOU STICK TO THE STUFF OUT
CALIFORNIA. IS A DUMPSTER FIRE
AND YOU HAVE CHOSEN TO SPEND
FINITE TIME AND LIMITED
LEGISLATIVE RESOURCES ON HR
SEVENTY EIGHT A REAL RESOLUTION
THAT DOES NOT AFFECT A SINGLE
CALIFORNIA WOMAN IN ORDER TO
PONTIFICATE ABOUT ABORTION THIS
RESOLUTION ILLUSTRATES THIS
BODIES INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS
RELEVANCY AND ITS INABILITY TO
RESPONSIBLY GOVERN CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSE HR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. HELLO MY NAME
IS ONE THAT SILLS AND I SERVICE
A DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE I SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS RESOLUTION WHICH WAS
SPONSORED BY OUR COUNTRY'S
LARGEST ABORTION BUSINESS
PLANNED PARENTHOOD. ABORTIONS
ARE DONE AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
UP TO SIX MONTHS OF PREGNANCY
WELL BEYOND BY ABILITY THIS IS A
GRUESOME BARBARIC TO DAY
PROCEDURE WHICH REQUIRES THE
DECAPITATION. AND DISMEMBERMENT
OF THE CHILD IN THE WOMB. IN H.
R. IF H. R. SEVENTY EIGHT WAS
CELEBRATING THE DISMEMBERMENT
AND DECAPITATION OF SO CALLED.
UNWANTED OR INCONVENIENT
PUPPIES. WOULD YOU STILL SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION SURELY WOMEN AND
CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER THAN
ABORTION. I HAVE READ THOUSANDS
OF WOMEN WHO HAVE ARRIVED AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD THINKING THAT
THEIR LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE SO
DIFFICULT THAT THEY WERE
CONSIDERING ENDING THE LIFE OF
THEIR CHILD. YET MANY WOMEN WILL
CHANGE THEIR MIND WHEN GIVEN
LEVINE HELP ASSISTANCE RESOURCES
ENCOURAGEMENT. JUST THINK WHAT
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SURPLUS COULD
DO TO ACTUALLY HELP WOMEN SOLVE
THESE OFTENTIMES FIXABLE
PROBLEMS RATHER THAN JUST
PROMOTING MORE AND MORE APPROVED
ABORTION. WE DON'T IN POVERTY BY
KILLING MORE POOR CHILDREN.
WOMEN COME OUT OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WALKING WOUNDED SOME
HURTING SO BADLY THERE ARE
BARELY ABLE TO GET TO THE CAR
LEAVING MANY WOMEN TO SUFFER
FROM DEPRESSION ANXIETY PANIC
ATTACKS NIGHTMARES DRUG ALCOHOL
ADDICTIONS. AND THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE FOR YEARS TO COME
ESPECIALLY WOMEN WHO ARE LIED TO
AND TOLD. IT'S JUST A COUPLE OF
CELLS. WE HEAR FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE WELL SCIENCE PROVES THE
HUMANITY OF THE CHILD IN THE
WOMB EVERYONE HAS HEARD THE
SOUND OF THE BABY'S HEART BEAT
WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE ULTRASOUND
IMAGES OF A BABY MOVING HIS OR
HER ARMS AND LEGS HER FACE. ALL
OF WHICH ARE UNDENIABLY HUMAN.
MAY THE MEMBERS OF OUR
LEGISLATURE BE ON THE POSITIVE
LEVINE LIFESAVING PRO LIFE PRO
WOMAN PRO SCIENCE SIDE OF
HISTORY FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON HR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM WE WILL
NOT TAKE ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY
BUT YOU CAN INDICATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO. H. R. SEVENTY
EIGHT MY NAME IS THERESA BRENNAN
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE RIGHT
TO LIFE LEAGUE AMERICA'S FIRST
PRO LIFE ORGANIZATION AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU OPERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONES IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
HR SEVENTY EIGHT AGAIN WILL NOT
TAKE ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY JUST
AN INDICATION. OF OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TO INDICATE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE LINE'S
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBERS. THE
FIRST GOOD LIGHT FORTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. TONY HARRINGTON
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
OPPOSITION. NINE FORTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT JOSEPH
BIRD I AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE HR SEVENTY EIGHT. LINE.
FORTY SEVEN. THIS IS MOLLY
SHEEHAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION TO IT ARE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE FORTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME WHEN YOU MORE
I'M FROM CALIFORNIA. I OPPOSE HR
SEVENTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU A PRETTY
MAKE CLOTHES LINES AND I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMON. THIS WORKS. I
WANT TO- ONE COUNTY OFF AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS TOGETHER AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK- AS I GREW UP-
IN POLITICS I THINK MANY OF US
THOUGHT THIS ISSUE WAS SETTLED
THAT. OUR MOTHERS AND OUR
GRANDMOTHERS HAVE FOUGHT SO HARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAD ACCESS TO
SAFE ABORTION. AND CARE HANNAH
OBVIOUSLY THOSE OUR RIGHTS ARE
BEING READ IT EVERY SINGLE DAY
ACROSS THE STATE SO IT'S
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA STANDS UP.
FOR WHAT IS RIGHT. I'M I HEARD
SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION HI CHRIS APOLOGIES
FOR WALKING IN LATE- I WALKED
INTO SOMEONE SAYING THAT WHEN
PEOPLE LEAVE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
THERE. I THINK WALKING WOUNDED
WAS THE TERM THAT WAS USED. WELL
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY EXPERIENCE
WHEN I HAD AN ABORTION WALKING
OUT OF PLAN HEARD WHEN I WAS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD I FELT.
CARED FOR I FELT SAFE. I FELT
THAT I GOT THE CARE THAT I
NEEDED THAT I WAS EMPOWERED AND
MAKING MY OWN DECISION THAT WAS
BEST FOR MY LIFE- AND SO I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND SAY THAT THAT'S
ANOTHER EXPERIENCE THAT HAS
HAPPENED- AND WANT TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT SEEING NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND FOR HER COMMENTS I WANT
TO SAY VETS LISTENING TO THOSE
COMMENTS AS A WOMAN. I AM
EMPOWERED HI I'M KNOWLEDGEABLE I
HAD THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIANS
INCREDIBLE AND NOW CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE SEXUAL EDUCATION. TO
ALLOW ME TO MAKE MY OWN
DECISIONS I DON'T NEED FOR THIS
TO BE LEGAL I DON'T NEED FOR
ABORTION BE CRIMINALIZED. I NEED
A PROVIDER WHO CAN HELP WALK ME
THROUGH THE DECISIONS OF MY LIFE
AND WITH THAT I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS AND WE CONTINUE. TO
STOP THE STIGMATIZATION OF THOSE
WHO SEEK AND ULTIMATELY HAVE AN
ABORTION AND THAT WE RESPECT
WOMEN'S RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. I AM
LOOKING FOR MOTION THE MOTION IS
THAT HR SEVENTY EIGHT BE
ADOPTED. I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THANK YOU HELLO PLEASE
STONE FIVE STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO BENNETT. BONTA
BONTA AYE DAVIES. KALRA HI KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES AYE WICKES WICKES I
. THE NEEDS ONE MORE SO WE WILL
PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU. THIS
BRADFORD ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. J.
R. SEVEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AS
J. R. SEVEN WHICH IS A- I THINK
RESOLUTION ASKING FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE LEGALLY.
GUIDON TAPES AND RECORDINGS AND
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE LATE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING. DR KING LED
THE MODERN DAY CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS
AND HE WAS ELECTED AS PRESIDENT
OF- THE MOB FAMILY IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN DECEMBER NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE. AND UP UNTIL HIS
ASSASSINATION FOR TWO THREE
YEARS AGO- WHILE LEADING THE
STRIKE FOR SANITATION WORKERS.
HE'S BEEN PRIED THE LEADING
FIGURE IN THIS COUNTRY- AND
CIVIL RIGHTS- WE WOULD I WOULD
HOPE ALL AGREE THAT TODAY HE'S
PRY REVERED AS ONE THE MOST
IMPORTANT. TO CONTROL LEADERS OF
OUR LIFETIME AND WHAT THIS BUT
DESPITE ALL THAT I SHOULD SAY-
THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS OF
HIS LIFE- IT'S HOME PHONE WAS
LEGALLY WIRETAPPED. THE OFFICES
OF SCLC WERE ILLEGALLY
WIRETAPPED HIS HOTELS OF MOTEL
ROOMS WERE ILLEGALLY WIRETAPPED
AND NEEDS TAPES ARE DUE TO BE
RELEASED AND TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
WE'RE CALLING FOR. IF NOT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THESE TAPES TO
HOLD THE WHOLE THESE TAPES THAT
THE SHOULD NEVER SEE THE LIGHT
OF DAY THEY HAVE NO HISTORICAL
OR EDUCATIONAL BENEFIT THE ONLY
REASON TO RELEASE THESE TAPES
NOW IS TO SULLY THE REPUTATION
OF A MAN WHO IS A NOBEL PEACE
PRIZE. WINNER AND FRIDAY BUT HE
SAID THE MOST LEADING ADVOCATE
IN THIS COUNTRY FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
FOR ALL OF AMERICA SO I SIT HERE
TODAY AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN-
JIM. WOOD JOIN US- HAS STATED-
J. EDGAR HOOVER- AGGRESSIVELY
AND HAAS WITH THE HAAST
HOSTILIUS SHOULD SAY. TARGETED
<c.blue>R MARTIN LUTHER KING FOR OVER</c>
EIGHT YEARS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
QCM OF ENGAGING AND COMMUNIST
ACTIVITY AND ONCE IT WAS PROVEN
THAT DR KING HAD NO WORLD AND
ASSOCIATION WITH CALMNESS PARTY
OR ACTIVITY THEY CONTINUE TO ALL
ILLEGALLY WIRETAPPED HIS HOME IN
THIS PHONE SO. OTHER FBI
DOMESTIC COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
PROGRAM KNOWN AS CONNOR INTEL
PAROLE DR KING AND HIS FAMILY
AND ASSOCIATES WERE SUBJECT TO
VARIOUS KINDS OF FBI
SURVEILLANCE. THAT EVEN SAID DR
KING A NOTE URGING HIM TO COMMIT
SUICIDE. IN ORDER TO AVOID
HUMILIATING HIM BY RELEASING
THESE- ILLEGALLY- GOTTEN
RECORDINGS AND TRANSCRIPTS. AND
AKORN'S UNITED STATES SENATE
COMMITTEE- CONVENED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TO INVESTIGATE DEATHS B.
I.'S DOMESTIC DOMESTIC I SHOULD
SAY INTELLIGENCE OPERATIONS TO
COMMITTEE DETERMINE THE
FOLLOWING RATHER THAN TRYING TO
DISCREDIT THE LATCH KAMIS. IT
BELIEVED WERE ATTEMPTING TO
INFLUENCE DR KING THE BUREAU
ADOPTED THE CURIOUS TACTIC OF
TRYING TO DISCREDIT THE SUPPOSED
TARGET OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY
THAT BEING DR KING. THESE
RECORDINGS ARE SCHEDULED TO BE
RELEASED AS I STATED BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES IN NINETEEN
TWENTIES AT TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
. ALL WHAT THE FBI DID TO DR
KING AND OTHERS WAS UNLAWFUL AND
IT'S AN INVASION OF PRIVACY AND
I THINK WE HAVE COME TO A POINT.
AS A COUNTRY THAT- THESE RECORDS
SHOULD BE DESTROYED. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS ALIGNED
DOMINICK DUNNE THAT. HE'S WITH
US ON THE TELEPHONE OPERATOR.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND MY NAME IS BONNIE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII
STATE CONFERENCE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE I AM HERE TO
SHOW STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. J. R.
SEVEN. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF COLORED
PEOPLE THE NWC P. WISE AND STILL
REMAINS ONE OF THE LARGEST AND
MOST INFLUENTIAL COOPERATE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES. DR KING CONVOLVULACEAE
WITHIN DOUBLE ACP DATES BACK TO
HIS POSITION ON THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE N. DOUBLE ACP
MONTGOMERY BRANCH IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES- HAVE GREATER
SHARE IN THE VARIOUS COPS
MARCHES AND RALLIES IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. BUT THE MARCH
ON WASHINGTON AND UP UNTIL. HIS
ASSASSINATION IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. BUT DR K. INFO NOTRE
COLOR RIGHT BACK AT THE FBI AND
ALWAYS TO KEEP FOR. THAT CAN.
WITH THE CAR PARTY. INVESTIGATED
USED RANGE FROM. HUNTING FORM
BUT HOTEL AND HOW FROM AMONG
OTHER THINGS. BUT NO ONE DOLLAR
WITH THE BIRD OF THE IN. I'M
WARRANTED FOR. MORE THAN DOC
KING. THE FBI DID. IN THEIR- TO
FRENCH BACK KING'S UNDER THE
PRETENSE PROTECT THIS KIND FROM
CON. YEAH THE ACTOR BELA IN
ACCORDING TO KING WERE MADE
WITHIN. TO DO HIS LEADERSHIP.
RIGHT AS A WHOLE. DR KING THE
LAST YEAR THE HIS LIFE WITH ANY
SEMBLANCE OF PRIDE. FOR CARRYING
THE TWO BIRD OF BEING A BLACK.
AND BUT IT'S NOT EVIL PARTIS. IN
HISTORICAL ATTEMPTS TO DEFAME
THE CHARACTER OF DR KING AND
INSTEAD EMBRACED HIS LEGACY AND
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO THE FIGHT
FOR EQUITY AND JUSTICE. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII
AND WCP I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THE SUBJECT AND I STRONGLY. URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SEE INTO OF ESTHER R. SEVEN.
SEEING NONE. OF ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINES ARE PRETTY WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR SUPPORT
FOR A STAY ARE SEVEN. THIS WEEK
IN SUPPORT OF SJR SEVEN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN HAVE KNOWING
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO A CA ARE SEVEN.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO
H. TWO S. J. R. SEVEN. YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO INTO IT UP
FOR THAT FOR OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE'LL CLOSE THAT
PART OF THE HEARING AND BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OR THEIR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT THIS
BONTA I JUST WANNA APPRECIATE
SENATOR BRADFORD AND THIS WEEK
ESPECIALLY AS THE C. L. B. C.
JUST HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE DR KING'S LIFE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PRESERVE AND HONOR
AT THE INCREDIBLE. LEGACY THAT
HE HAS OFFERED US AS A COMMUNITY
AND BELIEVE THAT MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
THE DOCUMENTATION THAT WAS
ILLEGALLY ACQUIRED ISN'T A PART
OF HIS STORY IT'S A HURT THAT
HAPPENED AT MANY YEARS AGO AND
THROUGH THIS AT THIS THAT
LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW US TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE IMPLORE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO REMOVE
THAT HURT THAT'S THE LEAST WE
CAN DO AS A COUNTRY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE. RIGHT
SIGNAL CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU- IN DR KING'S CLOSING
REMARKS WITHIN DOUBLE ACP
EMANCIPATION DAY RALLY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN. DR KING
STATED THERE'S NOTHING GREATER
IN THE WORLD THAN FREEDOM. IT'S
WORTH GOING TO JAIL FOR IT WORTH
LOSING A JOB FOR IT'S WORTH
LOSING YOUR LIFE FOR DR KING
LOST HIS LIFE FOR THAT FREEDOM
THAT WE ALL ENJOY TODAY. FOR THE
LAST FOUR AND A HALF YEARS OF
HIS LIFE. DR KING- EXPERIENCED
DEATH THREATS. AND HE LET HIS
LIFE LIVED HIS LIFE AS A WITH NO
SEMBLANCE OF PRIVACY OR FREEDOM
THIS RESOLUTION IS THE FIRST
STEP TOWARD RIGHTING THE WRONGS
DR KING IN MANY BLACK PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DORT AND CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE DUE TO ILLEGAL
SURVEILLANCE INVASIONS OF
PRIVACY BY THE FBI LOUDEST URGE
OUR NATIONAL ARCHIVES TO FINALLY
GRANT DR KING THE PEACE AND
PRIVACY THAT EVADED HIM WHILE HE
WAS ALIVE. BY DESTROYING THESE
TAPES OF THESE LEGAL LEAGUE GAME
TAKES A WE OWE IT TO THIS GREAT
MAN'S LEGACY TO DO SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
AND SECOND THAT MOTION. THAT S.
J. R. SEVEN B. ADOPTED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. SENATE BONTA BONTA
AYE DAVIES DAVIES HI KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS AYE REYES
AYE WICKS WITH FIVE. THAT HAS
BEEN ADOPTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOUNG- MEMBERS APPRECIATE
MR THANK YOU SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIX
SEVENTY SIX MR HOLDEN'S BILL
THAT IS BEING PRESENTED BY MS
BONTA. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB SIX
SEVEN SIX TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE WILL TAKE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO RECTIFY THE
UNBALANCED RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FRANCHISEE AND FRANCHISOR OURS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN AUTHORED AB FIVE
TWO FIVE WHICH MADE CALIFORNIA
THE STANDARD BEARER ON FAIRNESS
FOR THE FRANCHISOR AND
FRANCHISEE RELATIONSHIP. MEMBER
HOLDEN DECIDED TO TAKE ON THIS
ISSUE BASED ON HIS OWN
EXPERIENCE AS A FRANCHISEE. AND
THE STORIES HE HEARD FROM
CURRENT FRANCHISEES. PEOPLE
DOING THEIR BEST TO RUN SMALL
BUSINESSES DESPITE THE UNFAIR
CONTRACTS THAT FIGHT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN. AND DESPITE THE
PROTECTIONS UNDER AB FIVE TWO
FIVE THE PANDEMIC REVEALED. NEW
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR WHICH MUST BE
ADDRESSED. BETWEEN ADVOCATING
RESPONSIBILITIES TO FRANCHISEES
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND THE ELEVATION OF
UNFIT AND THE REVELATION OF
UNFAIR TESTAMENT OF FRANCHISEES
OF COLOR. IT IS CLEAR
FRANCHISEES NEED EIGHTY SIX
SEVEN SIX. THIS BILL DOES
MULTIPLE THINGS TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES. IT EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS
FRANCHISE ORES FROM INFLUENCING
WHERE A FRANCHISEE CAN PURCHASE
A FRANCHISE BASED OUT OF
PROTECTED CLASSES SUCH AS RACE.
RECENT LAWSUITS AGAINST
MCDONALD'S BY AFRICAN AMERICAN
FRANCHISEES. DETAILED THE
ONGOING ISSUES. SOME FRANCHISORS
HAVE LEVERAGE THE PANDEMIC TO
SHIFT LIABILITY ON TO
FRANCHISEES IN EXCHANGE FOR
FINANCIAL HELP. THE BILL
PROHIBITS THIS PRACTICE.
CURRENTLY FRANCHISE ORES ARE
UNILATERALLY DETERMINING THE-
AMOUNT FRANCHISEES- WHEN AN
AGREEMENT IS BEING TO TURN
TERMINATED ON. OR NOT RENEWED.
THIS BILL INCREASES FAIRNESS BY
GIVING BOTH PARTIES SA. AB SIX
SEVEN SIX WILL ALSO PROMOTE
ADEQUATE THE QUICK DISCLOSURES
AND ON. AND ENSURE THAT ALL
FRANCHISORS AND FRANCHISEES IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE COVERED BY THE
LAW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HAS
SPENT YEARS DISCUSSING THIS
ISSUE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
AMOUNTS TO COME. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WAS A
LAST AT LETTER OF CONCERN WHICH
IS ONLY MEMBER STAFF. IS
REVIEWING TO EDGE THOSE FROM AND
TIMELY. THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF
OF THE AUTHOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. I HAVE KEITH
MILLER HERE PRESENTING
REPRESENTINGFRANCHISEES HERE AS
AWAY. AS MY WITNESS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
ANSWER THE COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE.
AMENDMENTS I TAKE IT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IS TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY YES OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY MR REYES AND A SECOND
BY. THIS WORKS. OUR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
YEAH AFTER THE MOVE UP- I GUESS
. YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE TO GET ON
MY KNEES AND BEG OR SO NO
WORRIES IS NEEDED BUT THANK YOU
SIR STONE VICE CHAIR ALLAGHER A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY- HOPE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IS-
WATCHING IN AND I THANK HIM FOR
TAKING THE LEAD ON THE FRANCHISE
ISSUES AND THANK YOU OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA FOR STEPPING IN
TODAY MY NAME IS KEITH MILLER
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT AB SIX
SEVEN SIX ON BEHALF. OF ITS TO
SPONSORS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AT FOR MY ONSULTING
COMPANY FRANCHISEE ADVOCACY
CONSULTING TO BETTER ASSIST
FRANCHISEES AND CONCENTRATE ON
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT THE TRUE
INVESTORS IN THE INDUSTRY I ALSO
SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
FRANCHISEES AND DEALERS BUT
PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANTLY I'VE
BEEN A SUBWAY FRANCHISEE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT CURRENTLY WITH THREE
LOCATIONS IN GRASS VALLEY AND
OPPER. SO YES I HAVE SKIN IN THE
GAME SO TO SPEAK. THE OF THIS
BILL A SAMPLE IT'S TO BUILD ON
AND BETTER CLARIFY WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST. PROVIDE
BETTER- GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
ULTIMATELY BETTER PROTECT THE
FRANCHISE INVESTORS IN THE STATE
. WE NEED TO ENSURE FOR
CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE LAW CAN'T
BE WAIVED ON FRANCHISE LOCATIONS
THAT ARE LOCATED IN THE STATE.
NO MATTER WHERE THE INVESTORS
ARE. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
PROSPECTIVE FRANCHISEES BUYING
INTO AN EXISTING FRANCHISE
UNDERSTAND THE APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THE FRANCHISE
OR FOLLOWS THOSE STANDARDS. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT FRANCHISEES
ARE TREATED EQUALLY WITH
RESPECT. TO APPROVAL OR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE NO MATTER
WHAT THEIR CHARACTERISTICS ARE
OR COMPOSITION OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD YES. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THE FRANCHISE OR IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR VIOLATIONS OF
THE STATE FRANCHISE LAWS IF ANY
OFFICER AGENT OR EMPLOYEE
VIOLATES A STATUTE. AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT DISCLAIMERS ARE
NOT USED TO HIDE VIOLATIONS OF
THE FRANCHISE LAW THESE ARE THE
PRIMARY GOALS OF AB SIX SEVEN
SIX. AS ALWAYS WE WILL WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO ANSWER AND
CLARIFY QUESTIONS- TALK TO THEIR
LOBBYIST ON FRIDAY AND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE SOME LANGUAGE THAT WILL
DO AFTER THIS COMMITTEE- TO HELP
CLARIFY- AND WE CAN SOLVE THAT.
BUT THE REALITY AS FRANCHISE
OUTLETS IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
FALL UNDER THE LAW AND OFTEN THE
OPPOSITION WILL THROW OUT THAT.
IT'LL INCREASE LITIGATION FACT
THE MAP AREAS FRANCHISEES RARELY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO LEGAL
BATTLE AGAINST LARGE CORPORATION
OF THE FRANCHISE BRAND. A FRIEND
OF MINE SAID IT BEST MOST
FRANCHISEES CAN'T AFFORD THE
FREE CONSULTATION. IN CLOSING I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY CONTINUING
DISCUSSION AND ASK REAR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SEVENTY SIX.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SEVEN SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCHTONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. BOB GOOD
MORNING- COMMITTEE JOHN GORDON
IN SAN DIEGO I'M A RESTAURANT
ANALYST AND MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANT- I WORKED WITH-
PRECHECK THESE IMPRINTS AT- AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
ONE OF THE LINE IN CUBA WE'RE
PROVIDING THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WILL OPEN UP LINE
TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROY PARADES AND
IMA FRANCHISEE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT- EIGHT LOCATIONS
AND I AM SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. WHO NOW MOVED OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX SEVEN SIX.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR UP OPPOSITION
TO AB SIX SEVEN SIX. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE BE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE
WILL OPEN UP LINE ELEVEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STARTED GOOD
MORNING SEVENTH DOWN BY SEVEN
GALLAGHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEFF HANSON WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION I BELIEVE WE ARE THE
ONLY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION BATES
SO IF YOU DON'T MIND I'LL TAKE
ABOUT ONE MINUTE JUST HIGHLIGHT
A COUPLE OF OUR CONCERNS. WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MISTER
MILLER AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN'S- WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US ON SOME OF- SOME
POTENTIAL ISSUES WE BE WITH THE
FAMILY BUILT EXCEPT ME THANK
HOWEVER AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED- WE
DO- WE RANK BEGINNER MAIN
OPPOSITION. OF THE LEGISLATION
AS WE BELIEVE IT BOB CURRENTLY
I'M CLEAR CAN CREATE MORE
QUESTIONS THAN IT PROVIDES
ANSWERS TO AND ACTUALLY WOULD
POTENTIALLY GET INCENTIVIZE
BEHAVIOR- BENEFITING FRANCHISEES
AND ADDS MR MILLER- LET ALLUDED
TO MEDICAL WE DO BELIEVE IT WILL
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO AN INCREASE
IN LITIGATION BETWEEN
FRANCHISORS AND FRANCHISEES
WHICH- I'VE STATED. BUT THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY BENEFIT
FRANCHISEES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IT ALSO OVERALL
SEEKING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM WE
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED AND IS- REPORT
COMMAND LANGUAGE THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED CRAFTED AND ACCEPTED.
BY ALL PARTIES JUST A HANDFUL OF
YEARS AGO LED BY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY FIVE SO. THAT WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH ALL OF OUR POINT
BY POINT WHICH I BELIEVE YOU ALL
WE HAVE SUBMITTED WRITTEN
COMMENTS ABOUT THE FACT WE- LIKE
IF THEY BEGIN REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE LEGISLATION AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH A
MEMBER HOLDING. THAT MR MILLER
AND THE PROPONENTS TO HOPE WE
RESOLVE THOSE DIFFERENCES WITH
THAT. I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OF WITH NO FURTHER WE
HAVE FOR THE LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU UPPER TO MAKE
THE LINE OF RAIN TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR QUITE OR COMMENTS
. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE HI THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU MS BONTA FOR PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF MR HOLDEN. I WILL SAY
FROM A COMMITTEE STANDPOINT. TO
GET IN OPPOSITION LETTER VERY
VERY LATE IN THE PROCESS FOR A
BILL THAT HAS BEEN. IN PRINT FOR
A YEAR AND THAT SEEMS LIKE A BIT
OF A SCATTERSHOT OPPOSITION IS A
LITTLE BIT FRUSTRATING SO I'M
HOPING THAT MR HOLDEN. I THINK
THIS BILL IS IN GOOD SHAPE TO
GET OU OF THIS COMMITTEE AND-
HOPING WE WILL SUPPORTED TODAY.
BUT IF THERE ARE FURTHER
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S LETTER I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMITTEE IS
ENGAGED IN THAT PROCESS AS WELL.
AS WITH THAT. IS FAULTY MAKE
CLOTHES. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE- COMMENTS
FROM THE OPPOSITION. RELATED TO
THIS LEADING TO INCREASED
LITIGATION THIS BILL REQUIRES A
FRANCHISOR AND FRANCHISEE TO
AGREE TO FINAL TOTAL. OF DEBTS
OWED TO A FRANCHISOR THAT MAY BE
USED TO OFFSET THE BUYBACK OF
FRANCHISE GOODS ADOPTED IN AB
FIVE TWO FIVE. FURTHER MORE THAN
A GO SHE ASIANS EIGHTY FIVE TWO
FIVE NEVER CONTEMPLATED THAT THE
FRANCHISOR WOULD UNILATERALLY
SET AT THAT AMOUNT OWED. AND
IT'S BEEN SEVEN YEARS SINCE THAT
BILL WAS NEGOTIATED SO THIS I
NOT SOME TYPE OF DISINGENUOUS
JAILBREAK. AT THE STATE AND THE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF ALL THE
POLLS. THAT WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. SENATE HI BENNETT I
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I KALRA COVER AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION
AYE RADIUS. REYES AYE WICKS WITH
STEP BY. THAT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU PREFERRED. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ON.
THE CONSENT. CALENDAR CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER BENNETT. BENNETT I
BONTA BONTA AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
KALRA KALRA KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MENTORED IRIS REYES
AYE WICKS WEBSITE. THAT IS
APPROVED THAT IS S. B. TWO
EIGHTEEN BY MISTER JONES THAT
BILL IS HEADED TO APPROPRIATIONS
RIGHT LET'S GO BACK THROUGH THE
LIST MAKE SURE WE HAVE EVERYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO VOTE SO WILL
SORRY THINK WE HAD EVERYONE HERE
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE EXCEPT FOR MR
GALLAGHER SO LET'S GO TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TEN NINETY
THREE BY MR JONES SAWYER. THE
BILL IS OUT SO THESE ARE JUST
ADD ON'S SENATE FIVE SENATE I
MAIENSCHEIN. MENTION AYE WICKS
WEBSITE THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB FOURTEEN TEN RODRIGUEZ
IS ON CALL SO I'M GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BENNETT. SENATE I MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION AYE WICKS WICK SITE THAT
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU ITEM%
NUMBER FOR HR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
BAUER K. HAS ALSO ON CALL I'M
GONNA LIFT THE CALL. SENATE
SENATE I MAIENSCHEIN MENTION AYE
THANK YOU THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED I'VE NEVER FIVE THIS
YEAR SEVEN HAS BEENADOPTED BUT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BENNETT
. AN ANTI. RIGHT THANK YOU I
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES FOR US TO GALLAGHER
IN CASE HE'S COMING BACK. AND
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT. PROBABLY BECAUSE. HELLO
ALL RIGHT. YOUR CALL JEFF. SOME
PEOPLE ABSOLUTE. BOB HERTZBERG.
THAT'S WHAT THE GROUP OKAY SIX
OF THE. THE BILL THIRTY TWO.
HUNDRED AND YEARS LONG. THANK
WELL THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE. YEAH
HELLO. TRANSACTION YEAH OKAY SO
CAN YOU GALLAGHER ON CAN.
CALDERON CONSENT GALLAGHER I
RIGHT AND THEN ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHT SIX OF SIX HOLE GALLAGHER
- GALLAGHER I THANK YOU THANK
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS TODAY
MUCH APPRECIATED AND WE ARE
GERMANS.